samedi pour maxence et ses copains
c'était atelier musique
on a écrit une chanson pour un peu faire
réviser le spectacle de ce matin qui
parle depuis un combiné a alors 15 suite
non testé les instruments qu'ils avaient
ramené j'ai chanté avec le violoncelle
et la guitare avec simon bollinger ils
ont pu essayer des instruments simon
c'est le compositeur de la compagnie
tisseur de songe à l'origine de l'agent
mais marmailles et mahmoud destinés à la
jeunesse
c'est un sujet qui nous parle beaucoup
puisque au sein de la compagnie nous
sommes tous artistes pédagogues ce
dernier tous professeurs des
enseignements artistiques donc que ce
soit de théâtre de musique une journée
conclue par une farce celle d'angelo 10
mai olco dire usante qui revient de
guerre des textes anti militariste des
xvième et xviième siècle présent ce
paysan de soldats parti guerroyer pour
revenir et of plein de buts 1 qu on la
travaille sur un grand nombre
d'adaptations des traductions pour
vraiment avoir un texte déjà qu'ils
puissent être entendu qui puisse être
qu'on puisse dire est qu'on puisse jouer
et ce comme c'est un spectacle destiné
quand même un tout public et un tout
public jeunes à partir de 6 7 ans fait
aussi que le texte soit suffisamment
compréhensibles pour tout le monde et
c'est un spectacle qui mêle aussi la
musique
donc il ya deux chansons qui encadrent
le spectacle un peu vraiment la manière
d'un spectacle de très tôt un spectacle
presque un spectacle de rue cet éveil
artistique était aussi la conclusion
d'une semaine de travail
la compagnie était en résidence à
l'espace de covile de
voisins-le-bretonneux
non
[Musique]